tuesday marked as six months since
Hurricane Maria's landfall on the
southeastern coast of Puerto Rico the
category four storm knocked out power to
the whole island and caused widespread
damage leading to one of the most
expensive and logistically difficult
recovery efforts in US history
David beg no visited the island for an
update on where things stand now good
morning David
good morning Anthony we started our
journey by reaching out to followers on
social media to ask what were the
must-see spots based on those responses
we set out from San Juan to document the
good that's been done and the deplorable
conditions that still exist over thirty
five hours we made it to seven
municipalities and got a pretty good
sense of what life is like on the island
right now
we started in Caguas driving through
cognos we were told that locals are
starting to Don reflective vests and
direct traffic because most of the
traffic lights are not working
this guy is an example we're told just
helping out his name is William koto
he's been directing traffic here since
November even the police officers stop
and follow his directions and the
drivers tip him from here we headed to
Las piayed thus it's a woman reached out
to us on social media and said you've
got to see what conditions my bedridden
father has been living in for the last
six months we met the Santana sisters
who introduced us to their 90 year old
father Guillermo who's been in this bed
for three years and with no electricity
for six months on this day there wasn't
much of a breeze mr. Santana felt damp
his breathing was labored the day before
we arrived someone brought a solar panel
system that allows them to have the
light we have in the room allows them to
operate this respiratory machine you
must have been really happy when they
brought this response more or less we're
surviving but it's not easy
95% of the electrical customers in
Puerto Rico have power but 93,000 people
still do not hey David
welcome back to Puerto Rico thank you we
met Colonel Jason Kirk in the capital of
San Juan he's leading the US Army Corps
of Engineers which is helping the Puerto
Rican Power Authority restore
electricity you're here at the request
of FEMA right operating under the
authority of the Stafford Act that's
right what does the Stafford Act prevent
you from doing the Stafford Act is for
emergency response and you can't do what
prep owes Brid had aluminum transmission
towers I cannot put galvanized steel
instead of aluminum under the Stafford
Act you can repair and replace but you
can't upgrade that's almost always the
case the next day we traveled to jabo
KOA where the hurricane made landfall
with 155 mile-per-hour winds more than
half of the 38,000 people who live here
still do not have electricity and
desperation has a hold of them the mayor
told us a few days ago a local man took
his life a man in his 60s he lived at
this blue house right here apparently
the same day he was found hanging from a
tree the same day power was restored to
his house a suicide prevention hotline
center near San Juan reports that the
number of suicide related calls to the
hotline more than doubled from August to
January from Jabba Cola we headed west
to the mountains of Utah tow where
thousands of people like oedema Tatia
still do not have power or water did you
ever think about leaving
after Maria the bridge in Ooty auto was
wiped out some locals were stuck for
nearly six months but a week ago a new
bridge opened our last stop was in Macao
by the light of day it looks like
paradise but it's a living hell if you
ask the people who live here
driving through ou Macau we saw Alyssa
and her husband on the side of the road
with buckets they come here to this
faucet to get water because they don't
have it where they live and they haven't
had it for six months from there we went
to meet Luis Orlando he wanted us to
know about the problem people on the
island are having getting insurance
companies to pay them a fair amount or
pay them at all
the water was up to here Orlando lives
in a 98 thousand dollar home that an
insurance adjuster estimated had about
thirty eight thousand dollars in damage
you know what his insurance company
offered him eight thousand I had to make
a quick decision because I at the time I
had my family over there New Jersey and
I needed to bring him down here and I
needed the morning so you accepted the a
thousand well I was forced to accept it
as Wow
at least forty thousand people have left
the island since the storm and it's
unclear how many have returned Jamie and
Lisa a Moe's are two of the evacuees who
came back to give back water filters
solar lights and their time for some
reason it seems like in the traditional
u.s. culture its if I have I should
prepare for tomorrow
but here in Puerto Rico one of the
things that's so beautiful is that
people who have share and it seems
appropriate that if we are here and we
are living here amongst the people that
we can share with what we have David a
lot of people helping each other down
there some good things happening but
slowly yeah slowly butBut look here's
the good news
the shelves at the supermarket are stock
no more lines to get gas or at the bank
overall crime down about 20% however
murders just since January 1st an
alarming spike the governor says 150
already incredible you know you looked
at Macau you saw those power lines down
some people would say why not just bury
them they need to be replaced anyway get
rid of them you know it's interesting
the Army Corps Colonel said his dad
asked him that son why not just build it
underground and he said here's the
reason number one we don't have the
authority because we can only do
emergency repairs number two if we did
that it might take us two years or more
to get the lights back it's very
interesting the point that you make it a
piece about FEMA that that they can I
mean or about the military down there
that they can repair in place but they
can upgrade they have an opportunity to
now but they can't bingo and they said
to us the grid is not going to be
stronger or better than it was for the
next hurricane season but we at least
hope to have repaired everything that
needed to be when the season starts
two-three months away hard to believe we
go all right David Pegg know thank you
for joining us